[Music]
good evening guys um
another
grand master choice lecture here at the
saint louis chess club
i'm alexander shabolov and
we're going to be talking
about the uh we're going to look at talk
about a new emergent player
i'm
not sure what the name of the lecture is
but i i
there is this joke that
well on the half joke actually
that says
the current match in dubai that these
two guys are playing uh
that's a semi-final
okay those
they plan for the right
to play someone else after that match
and that someone else is going to be
talking about today
former iranian and current
french
player
world one for friends
on the recent european team championship
alireza ferruga
so
every day the
um
chess world uh become more and more
convinced that this this with
one of the players going to be in the
next match and
the second guy
will know the name in uh in a few more
days and in dubai
i think everyone has very little doubt
that it's going to be magnus but you
know
hopefully i hope so
that
ian still
has like something in him to
at least win
a one maybe two games
because
right now what's going on there just
like he's not even trying well
so hopefully tomorrow we'll see
what's going on there
okay anyway so uh elira is a
is he's probably second right uh after
beating mommy he be at least
uh he became second for
some time uh in the live rating player
yeah
life rating okay
and uh
you know a lot of top players of course
question and i've heard uh i've seen
kramnik saying that no not yet i mean
maybe five years from now
uh definitely
definitely some
signs of it you know that he might be
the next one
but not there yet and uh
it was echoed by a lot of a lot of top
players but uh frankly i don't really
understand why because looking at his
games i
i i see all the signs
i see all the signs of the guy who
still
you know has a lot of room to improve
and he's improving every day he's
growing up with every
game he plays and
um
to me the the biggest
sign that he will would be like
unbelievable threat in the next cycle is
that
the way he wins his
games okay um unlike the most of the top
players right now who are
oh once they get you out of the opening
get some advantage and it it's just a
flawless game most of the time
uh it's not what happening with ferruja
he's a
a lot of his games he's winning in waves
okay that uh
so he starts well and it goes his way
there's a mistake okay and games go back
to like somewhat
along equality alliance and then
the second wave he overplays his
opponent again and and then might be a
third and fourth wave and uh it looks
like he doesn't mind
doing that okay he's full of energy he's
very young okay uh
physically he doesn't look like super
overwhelming but i guess at this age it
really doesn't matter
okay well uh
it's enough health to
withstand long games like uh
and
i'm sure that
if he had to play like this game six
what we had in dubai uh
it wouldn't be
it wouldn't go that way it wouldn't go
magnus way that easily like how it was
uh
with what we saw there okay so
definitely
he is my peak to win next next cycle
and uh
whether or not he will be ready to play
magnus in two years we
yet to see
okay because well we saw ian was simply
not ready okay was like uh
he was not there unfortunately i mean
but uh we're gonna look at his games
we're gonna uh look at
his attacks uh
mostly from
the last tournament though he won
mm-hmm he impressively well won he tied
for first with fabiano so
congratulations to both players by the
way congrats to fabi to uh grab
candidate
sid
and my hometown of oh hometown my
town where i was born riga and latvia
and
i was a great tournament uh
with
two winners
caruana and
perugia
and there
i think eight more guys who made it into
grand prix and well
if anything if everything goes well they
still have chances to
fill up the remaining spots and
obviously
alex's sheriff
is my favorite out of the
remaining crowd
we'll see if there was a just uh one
tournament that he played well well
definitely was not a one turn because he
uh was very impressive at the european
championship as well but there was a
stretch it would will he be able to
carry the out through
the spring of 2022.
uh we'll see but uh
um yep i'll be rooting for him and
hopefully
some of you will join me in doing that
okay anyway so let's go
um
the first game uh it was against
jabala
it was towards the end of the european
championship when
uh oh by the way if you don't know the
results since well it's europe who cares
a french team
found this magic formula playing those
tournaments so
everyone
uh
well all the boards except for the first
one and just like from move one
are
trying to make like a draw which is a
and when three boards doing that
well guess what france wins the match
and uh
that formula worked perfectly and uh
france was about to grab the gold
uh team gold that european championship
and uh the last moment
ukraine uh
over overcame them uh you know on the
tie breaks
so this court same amount of points and
everything but some chess got decided
that you know
ukraine needs it more
this time so
but silver was still very impressive for
for the team which was
not such a threat to
any team tournaments recently and
with friday like everything has changed
okay
so they were playing uh georgia but uh
vador represents
these days
and
no i know in case you don't know who's
jabala is uh
the guy
probably has the biggest swings among
among elite players
so
i think less than two years ago he was
in
on on the brink of making like top 10 on
top 20 played all these top tournaments
and
now you see his rating below 2600 at
but everyone knows he's like on a normal
day he's like a 27 plus player it's uh
no questions about it the guy
uh has possesses all the qualities of
the top players uh he's been there
it's just
i guess
part of his personality part of his
lifestyle
uh
that
may i mean
permit such you know swings back and
forth like 150 points
in
in the
year span i mean
but
great player what can i say
so
let's go
e4 i
i really want to start with the moment
uh
in a deep middle game where
jabala thought that maybe he's a
kind of wrestling the initiative out of
the ferrugi's hand and
the moment he thought that this is the
case okay
he fell with him too and super
impressive attack in my in my opinion so
uh we get to that point and i will i
will ask you to start guessing moves
okay so
it's going to be interactive so uh
karakan a
little
it the opening is interesting and
for the reason
that kara khan is ferruja's main opening
against e4 right now so he plays this
himself
played a lot of games in riga with it uh
defended it despite like some
you know not such great positions and
so this is advanced karakan
e with e5
and knight f3 is a pretty quiet
continuation
uh
i already said in my previous lectures
with g4
current favorite of uh engine favorite
and
they think that black will
having a
hard time after
uh g4 at this point uh
it becomes like gradually it becomes a
weapon of choice for
for many grand masters so
if you guys
didn't
do it yet well pay attention to this
move the karakan players
it might be pretty soon it might be your
nightmare you know so knight f3 e6 bcp2
knight e7
oh
the main theoretical move when you need
to know a lot of c5
and
i know to uh
perugia did not
make
an impression right now as a
theoretical guy yet okay we don't see
too many wins uh
out of the opening
or just because like some novelties like
so definitely he's not uh like maxine
for example right or
or karana or magnus who can just like
demonstrate you the
uh
new idea in the opening and just just
sweep you off the board so and so he
tries to play without
opening that's why a lot of people
saying like uh
the guy's doing
this right he he's not trying to beat
the opponent right out of the opening
what is he possibly you know hopes for
on in the top in top chest like
well
you know when you have a lot of energy
and everything and
uh
i think that
magnus was doing for for a long long
time he just didn't want to see any
surprises in the opening and he was
doing great and
here we go
a4
typical plan for white i'm trying to
grab some space i want to put my pawn on
a5
take b6 square away from black knight on
d7 before i'm playing c4
so
no specific moves are not that important
bishop a5 uh
that's
there's nothing really new
uh but i think
yeah
uh as a result of the opening black was
not
not a bit worse okay
and like i said
uh unless
until the moment where jabal decided
that it's time for him to
you know probably
uh grab the initiative uh it looked like
you know white has absolutely nothing
so takes takes quincy three no yeah when
you see queen c3 you know that uh
which side is
trying to equalize tries not to lose
and here we go so this is the position
where
bishop c2 is happening so it looks like
this way
black wrestles the c file away from
white
and you know has all the chances
right
okay for those of you who think the
ferocious next challenge is a very funny
joke i mean uh
like i said i already explained my
reasons i think uh
uh
i
like
yeah it's uh
it could happen that it's still not his
cycle that he maybe needs like up four
years not two
but the way he plays the and from what i
see
how the other players do here
he's already there okay
so umar argued that
his end game is not up to the uh to the
task yet and his uh opening definitely
not there yet
uh and karana beat him and riga when he
needed he beat him on demand
but you know in two years everybody it's
all will be forgotten if it just goes
the the way it goes right now it it just
it goes super super fast and uh
well he uh he's my candidate he's my
candidate for next one even though of
course uh
if it will be
uh
no i mean seriously who is going to be
uh
kraken and rajabov
okay no
i just i don't even want to explain my
reasons give my reasons okay
uh
these two guys they're just you know
just because they're there
karana yes possible i mean
it might be
one of his last chances so he will be
very serious in doing that
uh nipple
going to be back
and we'll see about that it just really
it's not very likely right now so
um
who else the anyone who qualifies the
well wesley will try
to get into candidates we will see if it
uh
if he'll be able to do that
grace shook on
a fantastic player don't get me wrong
but well
he's not going to be a candidate
who else those uh eight people who
entered like grand prix from riga
none of them none of them just like her
so it's between corona and ferruja and i
think i'll give it to younger players so
uh
i i don't see it's like a a lot of uh
as a joke no not at all okay
all right
this is a position where black played
bishop c2 and looks like
he
asked well he threatens to take
well does he does he threaten to take on
c3 no he does not he wants to move the
knight from d7 first
and then
okay um
now that i'm starting to think is knight
a2 threat that black created
knight a2
it is a threat right if uh if it's black
to move again
this move
no it does not win material okay but
it forces white to take on c7
and then move the rook away and then
black will probably win the fight for
a c file and the wick with the weak pawn
on d4 no it will be a difficult defense
for for white so jabba created a threat
let's put it this way
and
[Music]
starting from here
it's a straightforward attack for white
right and uh
so
what's the starting move what do you
think
if we're talking about the attack
any idea
okay
okay so there's a pull takes a little
bit of a chat and i don't see the last
one so
is there any way i can move it a little
bit
yeah let me take a look
towards like huh
so i can see
some less
things in chat so
uh
i'm sorry hicaro is
didn't play a classical game in two
years i don't know what about
hikaru like are you asking if he is
still
has world championship aspiration uh no
he doesn't so
okay thank you
all right uh
do the ending
well what about do the ending
first of all they have to make it
make two candidates yet right
and uh
no if we compare and do that
and
fruit i don't think it's
the comparable at the moment
no he's not trash okay but
but
you know uh
he still has to win like anything closer
to what
uh
perugia did so
we got like a
he he's very sold and he is a very very
consistent and that's a big plus for him
but
uh any big wins from him yeah
no not there yet okay
due dates and candidates already
like how is that
from the oh sorry from the
from the world cup right okay sorry
yeah you're right that's not my my fault
of course yeah
it is there okay
okay maybe number three okay let's let's
leave do that number three as a
of my
rate no no i forgot that he he played in
the final that's that's right my fault
okay so no first move uh obviously since
we uh like i already announced that it's
gonna be a sweeping attack
uh
we should not give black any chance to
trade queens so
queen goes away right
oops
queen goes to g3 no that move is
and 28 no i guess like for
dybala
i believe that's
where he stopped like he saw bishop c2
coming g3 and he thought that queen d8
that stops g5
uh gets away from the pin
and again
i'm simply threatened to move the bishop
away and win the c file
or
i know there are better moves here it's
hard to tell
bishop takes d7
no i should have asked you like how how
white's supposed to to go for a g5
should
should he go like uh
h4 or maybe something else uh
the most
the simplest way takes on d7
and goes g5
so black
h5 prevents and opening the file
is not an option just drops the pawn
for
okay knight takes knight d3 and rook
simply moves away and then knight goes
to f6 and it's going to be a checkmate
so
so he has to take
okay
um
queen takes
okay i'm glad like it's 65 percent
saying
uh through the
next world champion
okay well
28
no okay well
why to move and again um
since
we're attacking we're not trading coins
we need to
put it somewhere where the block cannot
attack it and
so choices between
qnh5 check i think when g3 coin g2
the queen h5 check
pushing the black king towards the
safety uh probably out queen g4 the
bishop f5 and
so queen goes to black square there dark
sort no queen h5 okay
i already forgot what happened in this
game yeah
why not queen g3
i don't know okay check here we go
and knight f3 so temple play
g6
rook g1 so suddenly uh white attacks
with all four pieces okay unfortunately
he cannot
none of his pawns can join really uh h
pawn on h5 would be fantastic of course
but
there is not enough space for
all the white pieces to to be on this
short uh
on this part of the board
so he tried it's an attack with pieces
it's it's actually a really
hard thing to do it's like
it's much easier to attack when you have
a pawns that can open up the position
then
uh attack was just pieces alone
okay
so knight c6
no um
jabala is a strong player he realized
that you know
if uh white goes knight h4 right now
then despite
the fact that he will have to sacrifice
on g6 something no four pieces will
break through so knight quickly tries to
return to e7 and that's the idea of this
move
queen h6 queen of f8 queen h4
so
pause for a second he poses for a second
uh creates like a different kind of
threat says knight h5 knight f6
there's knight g5 there
so
queen g7
okay and
knight h5
no ever since logical then black has a
choice now between queen h6
and
queen h8
i think this is where jabal makes
mistake
when queen goes to
f6
rook g4 excellent
excellent attacking move and uh
when we are analyzing the the game like
this right all these moves and don't
look that that difficult and hard but
in the real
in
real
uh time over the board
to
attack that precisely uh
it is very impressive so
rook goes g4 you need you when you plan
this move you immediately need to see
the idea like um queen f6 and rook h4
that
rearrangement of pieces it's not easy to
see from here actually he had to see the
whole sequence starting from uh knight
h5 here right rook g4 knight h5 rook g4
and f6 rook h4 white had other options
as well
so
it's great when you see a great attack
from uh
in the real time it always very
impressive so queen f6 has been promised
okay
and
queen takes h5 rook h4 no obviously
is knight g5 even better uh
no
it's like rook h4 is enough we don't
really need to
and
knight d8
rook h4
king goes back to g8
knight g5 comes in
and bishop d1 i'm i i it looks it seems
to me i don't know but uh no in jabal i
think he was still thinking that he's
doing okay okay well obviously time
trouble and everything
but
after bishop d1 now i want you to tell
me how
how white finished this finish this game
okay
yes it panko yeah that's a good one but
well
maybe
in the next one not not in this current
one
uh
this is interesting like uh when you
send through genetics kasparov and
camaro uh
would be interest uh
interesting to do a little different
parallel here okay when i was uh
listening to
cronic the other day uh
you know talking about the match he uh
remembered how like in the beginning of
90s in the span of two three years the
top ten of the world was completely
replaced by new players
so instead of like lubovic and
and
who else like team under all of a sudden
there was like uh
an ant
there is kramnik there is girlfriend
uh there is sheriff there is kamsky it
happened in the span of two three years
so right now there is no threat of like
a top ten will be replaced at the in two
three years there's uh
but the names that you are
bringing that definitely
uh
they will be participating so
it's interesting to see if keemer uh
will
make it into top 10 in two years right
or dude is already there right and um
ferruja is already there but it's only
two is a panko um
two years
don't see it yet okay nobody does i
guess but uh plays strong this
uh certain games are super super
impressive but uh
well
not there yet so if we are looking
through the same process that happened
in beginning of 90s when the
top 10 was replaced in just two years
that's interesting to see and i think
this grand prix in the
spring will
give a lot of answers to us okay
if there is like new players will emerge
and
uh there are a lot of names that could
could be on in
in the mix there is uh there are those
those back players that did absolutely
fantastic in
our world cup
and um
i know young armenians
well that did so well uh online
okay would they be a threat was that for
real
well we'll see that okay
all right
go ahead what's white did now any idea
beautiful finish by
beautiful finish by eliriza
knight takes f7 is interesting but
what's the follow-up yes okay
uh if you're suggesting something how
about giving me the whole line just not
don't say like qnh8 and just that's it
okay
uh
just give me a couple more moves all
right
yasipanko
plus score against magnus out of what
two games
it's
not enough okay
um
queen e7 and uh
bishop takes h5 what's the point
how are you going to win that
kimmer nihal yeah oh i'm sorry of course
i forgot about the
like uh
how to describe all the young indian
players all together it's just a
bunch and uh you know
army it was like
um
yeah of course all those guys nihal and
arjun and like
yeah
no
okay so tebow
gets me
a final answer yeah so the move uh
jabawa did not
see and uh white had to see it at the
moment he played knight h5
is queen d8 it was like a
like a bolt in the sky for jibawa i'm
sure that uh
okay black has to take
and a nice checkers combination check
take a queen
knight takes f7
and picks it up
so total checkers you know in the end uh
you're given
you're given one
and then you're picking up the rest of
it
so
uh
well attack itself maybe it's not it's
not that hard the the separate move it's
just a speed which we i remember
watching this game live and i thought
well what an
unclear position and
uh what is it going to do like uh
it's the
typical position where jabal like
actually doing pretty well unclear with
mutual chances you know the play on both
sides of the board
and then
less than 10 moves later he resigns to
queen takes d8
uh
to me well
that's that was a
a real real sign you know of something
going on too
okay anyway so uh let's keep going
hello everyone
yep just reminding that
we are
replaced okay let's replace it
so
ill mask yeah that game okay uh again
we're not gonna go through the whole
game it's just like with uh
i just want to show you that he is
strategically he's there already okay
if he wants to do something he finds a
way and there is no
like there's no stopping him
so
uh
mustafa yilmaz uh
i guess i'm not sure if he's top turkish
player number one world one
or not but uh
again a great performance in the world
cup so
i guess if you if he was playing fairly
on board one and uh european teams so
he
he is a bored one for turkey okay pragna
is strong but uh yeah let's give him
a little bit more time
to develop
yeah
okay bishop e3 yeah let's go to the
point uh
where i want to
us to concentrate so
right oh sicilian neidorf
not the most
dangerous line for for black
and
after the play on a king's side they're
kind of blocked right the
uh white find himself on in the
situation where if he wants to win this
game he has to open the queen side
so basically he has to play c4 open up
the queen side and then use the fact
that he is both pieces
knight and the bishop are participating
in fight
in fight on the queen side and black
knight on h5 on bishop on e7 or not
so in other words the white has a
firepower advantage on the queen side
and he needs to open the problem is of
course that black will not be
cooperating you will try to play c4
i will play b4 you will not be able to
open the c file the rook will not be
able to join
so
let's see how for you to make sure it's
it happens so first of all
okay
there is no direct way of doing it just
like uh if you go c4 immediately
uh probably goes to c8 and you cannot
even
appease the seat point you cannot really
do much he takes so he takes his time
uh so patience is there okay unlike uh
unlike
one of uh
uh dubai players right now right uh
we'll see that
uh he takes his time if he needs to so
like i said he's not really up
against the idea
not to win the game right away if he
needs like to win it in the second and
third wave of uh
attack he'll he'll do it so c3
g6 whatever so he doubles first
and
black here to
meet it right here so again uh if white
plays c4
black will simply play b4 and opening
the c file without like a tons of
exchanges will be extremely difficult
so how
can white ensure
that
c file gets open here
what's the
what's the idea of like doing that
what do you think
how we can play c4 so that the block
cannot
play before
as an answer
so we need these two rooks in the play
right okay
wesley next challenger
quite possible a4 is interesting okay
let's see a4 that was a suggestion right
so
and how do you go how are you going to
open the c file here
if i'll just take
so just to justify this two rooks like
looking at his own points
okay c4 and c5
that's not a bad idea but like i said
the problem doing that is that uh it's
gonna lead to tons of exchanges
and uh
for example with what if i'll take right
bishop takes and
i know something like knight to
f4
uh
is that gonna be
is that easy
um
not really right not that
clear pretty unclear situation
okay
i see yep
i see
the correct answer already so
in order to stop b4
white has to put his own piece over
there
and that's what b4 and that's what
that's what he does okay
uh
you know i played a lot of uh i played a
lot of night off with both colors and
i've seen a lot of neither
this is absolutely fresh idea i've never
seen anything like that
okay um
really really cool and i'm sure this uh
over the board inspiration for this guy
so um
before
exactly it seems scary and uh
all the instincts that the chess players
like when we start learning chess and
the
coaches telling us like
pawns that cover and the kink you know
never touch them you know every time you
touch them you uh it creates a weakness
in it
well here
we're trying to break through over here
before
okay black says
i'm ready for your c4 okay
try to do this i'm like
you'll play c4 i'll take on b4 and you
still cannot open the c file
so what's next
what's next
uh a4 doesn't block unfortunately for
black a4 doesn't block because uh white
will play c4 anyway
the white to move next how how do we
make sure that c4 comes in
we have to somehow
quintex b5 is really scary like opening
the b file like this uh
it's uh
i know rook b8
also
yeah we might win the pawn but we failed
to
achieve what we really wanted to do
which is open the c file so
now
almost for sure that c file is not going
to get open
queen a4
and then i don't know knight f4 to start
with maybe d5 rook c4
um on clear situation that definitely
it's strategically it's wrong because c
file remains closed
how do we open the c file
we need to force black to
take on b4 so for the c file to get open
um
yeah i great wolf uh that was a good uh
[Music]
good remark uh bishop bishop takes e7
and rook takes c6 i was also
looking at it but i think it's knight
takes d5
rook takes c6 and queen takes e7 you
only have uh what uh
a piece on a rook for a quinn i don't
think it was clear right
knight b3 okay knight b3 is interesting
but knight i'm already threatened to
take on b4 so
knight b3 and i'll take on b4 or
you cannot take back
so this is extremely tense moment so
next white moves
white move is
sort of
if white doesn't have a move right now
then what he did it was just stupid
okay
yep
and here we get uh the answer from trent
that's a4
okay so it was not enough to push the b
pawn forward let's do
a pawn goes forward as well
so and now we see how all white pieces
are participating in attack okay rooks
are defending c3
bishop takes away b6 from the rook
knight takes away c4 from the rook and
that's the difference while these two
pieces are away from the
action
uh white is using all his five pieces to
do something
uh
you cannot take on a4 because b5 wins uh
an exchange
so
black takes on b4
okay and now comes the
like the
kind of
the
star move of the combination
for white
which is what
uh can i draw arrows uh i'll
learn to do that next time okay i mean i
should be able to okay
um
why does why does white win on exchange
okay hold on a second
uh
you're asking like why do white wins on
exchange here because the rook doesn't
have square to go to
you have to give it up on either on c4
and c5 or on b6 and that's that's an
exchange right
okay
so
again
that's what happened in the game and why
to move
okay i already see yeah a couple of
people
uh
amazing james gunn and mark martinez
correct move is queen takes c6
so
super cool i mean
like i said i've seen a lot in chess
probably i mean
for 40 plus year of my chess career i
mean i've seen a lot of things what i
see from frida is
is new i mean i i haven't seen those
things in a very very long time
okay
so black has to take
and just this one
and guess what now the absence of a
knight on a coincide becomes especially
clear for example if black exchanges
everything
uh takes on c2
twice takes on a4
and b pawn will cost him at least the
bishop pro maybe
it will be queening if
if white will take his time so
it has to do this
and then
the rook is the only piece that can
possibly stop a pawn
so we need to keep it and of course
we're keeping the x 1 right so a5
so this pawn combined with white three
pieces will be winning so knight f4 no
the rest is easy for it
for anyone
you don't have to be
a farouja to do that
well still some
interesting moves that i would probably
not
play like rook d5
okay
there we go and here
uh you must resign because i will take
on b5
next move then rook goes to b7 and
knight joins and well
there is no way this pawn can be stopped
so
very short confrontation on a queen side
it only took like uh let's see like
starting from c3 how many moves it to so
he got an positional idea that he needs
to play c4
and then he does it in one
two
three
four
five
six moves
so i'm don't know if he saw queen takes
c6 the moment he played rook c1 uh
that would probably be a stretch
but
again
like uh we're talking about strategic
plan
here we go the middle game what he does
on the middle game right now and
uh
is doing it better than anyone in the
world okay
maybe other than magnus yeah
so
okay
and do we have time for
one more i have fragment we should
let's see
i'll load next game
which one will be the next one erdos
what was there um
let me
yeah that uh it's very impressive game
but it it probably will take more time
so uh let me
go for some
short fragment uh as the last one
switch
yeah okay uh
uh darius uh switch uh another player
from saint louis okay
uh
played in the u.s championship this year
um
actually gave him a really hard time and
uh in this game and in the beginning
fairuja was seriously worse probably his
worst position was black pieces
during the whole tournament
but then he recovered and the
that easiness with which he uh won
a technical position like yeah somewhere
around here
white white is much better of course and
then recovery
and
after
a blunder
over here yeah that that last move
uh by white no actually the whole idea
taking on c6 and going e5
is a blunder uh
fuji immediately spots his double attack
after queen h for
knight g3 check when in exchange right
or and the knight on c4
so rook f3
takes takes
d7 he picks
a couple moves later we we're going to
get the position that uh
which is technically not that clear
right a rook a7
uh
white has a rook and pawn for two nights
which is if any of those knights would
be a bishop we would not be discussing
it clearly black is winning but two
knights versus rook
are not that effective okay they're just
like especially if if we for example if
we take the queens off the board uh
white white is probably better
but because queens are on the board this
is a technical technically winning
position for black
the easiness which
with uh
how he won this position is just like uh
another sign to me like that he he might
be already be there okay despite
uh obvious
minuses yet and everything so
yeah past pawns are scary position like
to me if i was if i was in the game here
i would be like um
uh i don't know what's going to happen
right
to furuja there were no doubt like a
single moment that this position is
winning for black and that's how he
played and that's what the result was so
let me actually switch the
flip the board and
knight f5 all moves are to the point
there is like a no time wasted and uh
activating his pieces
on
b5 93
no hesitation and that regard like the
way he won this position he uh he
reminded me of kasparov you know the
in his best moment like against karpov
and
so
everything to the point there is like an
like king sound here right
i mean
you need the confidence uh to play a
move like this and
he does it
when he knows when he's winning i mean
it's really hard to play him
rookie four
beautifully
and
knight takes his no this position
probably won in many different ways uh
but uh
i like
the way he finishes the rook takes h2
so what's the win after queen takes h2
okay yeah if uh
if haru just said that that is part of
his favorite player i mean no no wonder
i mean i i that's what he reminds me of
at certain moments
uh how does black went from here
king juan keep going
king h1
very good okay uh
this is what like in every beginner's
book that's probably what they start
with they teaching you that it's called
anastasia check mate right
and they give you like an examples like
how is it uh you know beginners becoming
a victim of anastasia mate here we go
like two beginners right the one soon to
become a
challenger then and the other is like a
a super strong player who was leading
uh
the us team in online olympiad i believe
he was playing board one right and
that's uh
so anastasia checkmate check here
knight takes scores away takes takes and
takes so
cool
um
oh
i guess this is where uh i'll stop
okay uh
there were a couple of games that i
really wanted to show you but we simply
don't have time um
if you really want to see something
impressive from him how about
uh
oh was it
no that wasn't blitz
there was one game against tyronian that
was so complicated that it was almost
yeah this was one pain to watch okay
okay i didn't know it was a blitz game i
thought it's more or less normal time
control but uh
uh
yep he beat aronian and uh on uh
in iranian position pretty much like
um
it's very good anyways uh
you've heard me guys i i think we were
uh dealing with the next challenger here
the guy
who's going to win
next candidates but uh that's just me
okay what do i know
uh
your opinions everything just let me
know
and
i'll
see you guys next week
[Music]
you